and all stereotypes have been affirmed
the bad guys is bringing a story to the
screen that's never been seen quite like
this we're covering the animation the
actors the music the dancing and
everything else that made the bad guys
so uniquely different hop in not letting
me in try rebooting oh my gosh you fixed
it number one lights animation action
it's a blend of silliness and
sophistication of cool and stupid the
animation style of this movie is
something fresh for sure feels kind of
like an ocean's eleven for
young people given it's like the first
heist movie for children it's borrowing
a lot from tarantino because it never
had been done before in animation the
opening sequence is an obvious nod to
pulp fiction and was one continuous shot
let's do this
number two tarantino meets miyazaki the
animated stories they took inspiration
from were anime including that of hayao
miyazaki and cowboy bebop i wanted to
make it my own french sense of design
influenced by a lot of the anime style
the idea was to mix and blend mediums to
try and break the mold when i saw my
character for the first time i was like
she's cute i'm adorable number three
where can you find a better source of
inspiration than the book it really was
that first cover of that first book the
animation style of the book alone is so
unique one thing that made the animation
stand out was going back to some
traditional technique and layering those
2d elements on top of the 3d image they
aimed for a more illustrative style by
keeping the brush strokes visible this
film was really about trying to remove
the details that we would normally work
really hard to add oh and something that
changed a bit from book to film is in
the book miss tarantula is mr legs
number four choreographing animated
anthropomorphic animals sounds easy as
pie
susan meisner was the choreographer on
the bad guys her goal with the
choreography was to try to start with
the story first she leaned into the
competitive and playful nature between
mr wolfe and diane because i kept
thinking a fox and a wolf what can they
do not only a fox and wolf but larger
than life animated creatures and so she
was pushing the actors to their limits
she's worked with sam in the past so she
knew how he worked already
number five what playlists are you
adding this song to
the song good tonight sung by one mr
piranha aka anthony ramos wasn't even in
the movie until the last second they
could squeeze it in it was starting to
look it was starting to look like insane
it would have been a shame to not
include anthony's singing voice
yeah i cut the record and i made it in
the movie number six the score is
anything but settled the director didn't
want your classical score but a mix of
jazz funk and rock the sound is meant to
harken back to the classic heist movies
of the 60s and 70s but it also has its
own different feel so they had a lot of
fun with the music and were able to get
really big they wanted to craft a score
that supports different themes and story
lines the song meet the bad guys is a
personal favorite of the composer
because he had to not only score a car
chase but each new character as well
since they introduced each one
individually in the middle of the heist
and it made for quite the challenge
number 7 sometimes the first timers are
uncorrupted by the status quo if you put
a frenchman at the lead you're going to
get something
magnifique this was pierre parafell's
directing debut when it came to feature
films the reason he took on the bad guys
is because he had a fully realized
vision for it despite his background in
animation he only animated one little
thing for the movie you can see it at
the end when there are three little
birds flying across the screen which he
only animated out of necessity for him
the idea behind the movie was to make it
a gateway or entry point into the genre
because he doesn't think action movies
like this have been done that much in
animation he didn't want to talk down
the audience too much either okay
there's the message let's not be preachy
pierre took some inspiration for the
movie directly from himself he felt that
he was going through a bit of his own
mid-life crisis and funneled that into
the wolf you know you need somebody's
slightly hard to understand because then
it makes you listen more
number eight with a script this
interesting it would be hard to say no
to a role everybody involved in casting
put lists together of who they thought
would be good in the roles and the
director was happy that every actor
chosen was on his list it was actually
rather easy i gotta say the first actor
approached was sam rockwell the usual
suspect would be george clooney but the
director wanted more than that pierre
has been a fan of sam since his first
movie sam saw the presentation with the
trailer artwork film music he said yeah
that sounds like heaps of fun i'll do it
everybody was given a copy of the books
to read which sold them on the project
marc maron took on the role of snake
because he was surprised somebody wanted
him to do the role at all that and he
felt he could relate to the character go
bad or go home
number nine we wonder if anybody went
method for their role
aquafina enjoyed her time as a spider i
want to channel someone who was really
good at what they did and had total
control over that it seems like she and
alex sportstein had something in common
i like in general playing no-nonsense
characters that especially women who
know what they want lily and zasey
enjoyed the voice acting process because
they are incredibly expressive people
and film can usually force you to stay
very subtle so being behind the mic was
freeing less free was craig robinson who
wasn't allowed to improvise all that
much but he did get to play with the way
he spoke each line and worked with the
director a lot to refine the different
voices of the different characters he
played confused we're talking about
characterception a character within a
character his favorite character voice
was the pregnant woman but he also found
himself struggling with his french
accent keep cool baby
birthdays should be chill number ten
some actors got special privileges
the director pierre really wanted to get
people together to record for this
project thanks to a certain pandemic
they had to record separately for the
most part as the actors were all over
the country as well mark maron and sam
rockwell were the only actors who really
got to work together in the studio for a
truly meaningful amount of time they
spent a lot of time refining their
character dynamic because it was at the
heart of the story and important to get
right but out of all the people in the
world
i hate you guys the least number 11.
fast cars are what make action scenes
good right you don't do an action scene
without knowing where the goal of your
character if you do an action scene for
the sake of an action scene the audience
will get bored
very quickly the dance scene has a lot
of layers for this reason and the
director's question was how to subvert
the expectations of an action scene so
that it becomes a unique version of that
action itself and the stylization was
all very important the lighting the
color the style of the motion
number 12. first reads aren't always
fantastic the cast's first time reading
together was over zoom and even still
the acting was on point excuse me
is this the biggest rift the cast were
busting a gut over how funny the script
was and you know what makes a good table
read a great table read it's the
narrator no not mr wolf the guy reading
the stage directions or rather the
business of the screenplay
motion sensing lasers can attract wolf
and snakes every movement the bad guys
is one wild ride we can't help but love
the direction that animated features
have been taking these past few years it
feels like studios are really starting
to take more risks now that animation
has caught up with imagination if you
could play any one of the bad guys which
would you choose let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things